en su primer día de visita a Sudán del
sur el Papa Francisco pronunció en el
Palacio presidencial de Yuba capital del
país un discurso rotundo y contundente
denunció las dramáticas consecuencias de
la guerra civil que ya ha causado en
este país la muerte de más de 400.000
personas y ha obligado a millones de
habitantes a huir de sus hogares el
pontífice mencionó el acuerdo de paz
firmado en 2018 un acuerdo paralizado
lamentó el Papa Francisco en presencia
del presidente salvar y su rival
político el expresidente riek machar los
dos enemigos que seguirían enfrentándose
a través de milicias interpuestas grupos
armados acusados de atroces crímenes de
guerra hoy el pontífice expresó su
indignación basta dijo Francisco Basta
ya de sangre derramada basta de
conflictos basta de agresiones y
acusaciones recíprocas hay que dejar
atrás el tiempo de la guerra dijo el
papa quien exhortó a los violentos a
escuchar el grito de todo un pueblo que
llora y hacer concesiones es necesarias
para aplicar y relanzar el proceso de
paz para dar un respiro a los habitantes
de este país martirizados que aún sufren
las terribles consecuencias de la guerra
aquí en Sudán